the minions
[Music]
I hated shower there's his conspiracy
going along that they put an X on me do
not fully acknowledge me great
conspiracy you did today we're going to
Universal because my call time is not
until 6 p.m. and you bros are coming ok
we're here I'm so confused
what is going on do you know where to go
okay well we're just gonna walk
[Music]
I thought Universal is a theme part but
it seems like it's just it is
I'm so confused what's going on we're
here let's check out some rights
we are connecting with a stream of
people ok first ride will be this one
hello I grew what's your name where
you're from wow that might be the
productive question trusted questions
[Music]
[Music]
Oh fine
okay I'm gonna beat Marzia you're going
down I don't even know how to play yes
alright guys we'll start when the buzzer
goes off what
[Music]
I got this what what was the process you
in a minyan yeah he was reaching out he
wanted a hat what about that can I touch
that okay sure thank you all right
thank you you wanna dance
Wow it looks pretty real breakfast yes
all right might say are we kids or are
we adults yes all right
the ultrasound is right in my eye what
the [ __ ] that is
[Music]
brofist you never happen on Eroica
brofist yes say you guys
he sat next to me on the ride we didn't
recognize me until I said brofist okay
I'm gonna go on this one
might see I was too scared which is okay
I'm a little worried I hope it'll be
okay
crazy
which one should I do you pay oh I love
those
give me those Santa's Little Helper it
is it's my turn to win this way
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
I want to thank my mom what am I gonna
do with this Maggie now enjoy the ferris
wheel but whatever this is a thin
pleasant experience the doors open into
maybe infinities we're going up whoa oh
my god what
[Music]
oh no more right all right we're done
for today we're heading back it's a lot
of fun I enjoyed it I denote as my shoes
got even worse yesterday what is he
doing why is there blood everyone thinks
I'm in fear of the walking day
maybe I am this shoot is delayed one
hour why are you giggling like a nerd
whoa you looks gangster I'm scared
mr. Merz oh I got some guys oh yeah here
[Music]
man that is pimping people got so pissed
I had a Raiders cab I don't know I I
forgot to tell you four days for legend
of the brofist you can't see it they're
like us what is this
it should learn parity buy into our trap
who is that
[Applause]
thanks Jack that's not awkward awesome
so Jax I will help me there ya go
one of the most common questions about
legend of the brofist is will the game
be for free can i download it for free I
don't want to pay for something
imagine that you worked on something for
seven to eight months and you didn't pay
yourself any money at that time and you
spent your all your own money into a
project and then for people to want that
thing that you create
for free and not pay for it insane I
don't know why people want games to be
free games that are free are usually a
terrible gaming experience because
they're filled with micro transaction or
advertisements and it's not free and
it's not fun so we decided very early
that we wanted the game to be a fair
price which is for 99 dollars and to be
the best experience that you could get
and we can't do that if the game is free
so I hope you understand and I really
hope that won't turn you off from from
wanting to play the game because it's
really really a good product and I think
your brothers are really gonna enjoy it
I know that it'll definitely be worth
your money I just wanted to be clear on
that so thank you for understanding all
right
I was randomly browsing Twitter and you
remember their live before there was a
guy who didn't recognize me
until I said brofist I saw his tweet I
still can't get over the fact that I
rode next to Peter PI on Jurassic Park
and didn't even know it was him and
there we are it is I can't see 10:00
p.m. we're eating ice cream another very
productive day at shooting very good I'm
sure the people who's paying for this
show is very satisfied with the use of
our time okay we just wrapped another
day I'm gonna go and wash this off this
hand has been in the toilet but it's not
[ __ ] let me tell you it's worse than
[ __ ] it smells like [ __ ] and
all right I'm so tired I'm just gonna go
right to bed tomorrow I'm flying to San
Francisco to check it out cuz we got the
weekend off
but for now thanks for another awesome
day I'll see you bros tomorrow